so I'm going to show you something today
which is notable because it's a total
scam on two levels this is sort of rare
Alex Jones still has a show conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones he has a show it's
not really appearing in many places
because he's been banned from YouTube
Facebook I think Spotify and others
Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
had a complete and total meltdown over
Ivermectin okay in the segment Alex
Jones purports to take ivermectin for
his audience to prove to them it's safe
and it's great now there are two scams
here and I'm not going to say either is
more important to understand than the
other both are really important to
understand the first scam is that Alex
Jones doing this means anything about
the safety or efficacy of ivermectin for
covet when we've actually looked at
studies there are no actual rcts
double-blind rcts randomly controlled
trials
that tell us Ivermectin does anything
good prophylactically or for active
active treatment of covid uh you look at
Joe Rogan who took Ivermectin and six
other things for something from which
most people recover anyway right I mean
doesn't mean we don't take it seriously
but most people recover and you see that
he took Ivermectin and azithromycin and
monoclonal antibodies all these
different things that's not anything
that doesn't that's nothing that doesn't
tell us anything when you look at actual
studies the study people tend to point
to on Ivermectin is an Egyptian study
where there was Ivermectin versus
hydroxychloroquine no placebo group
it's it's not rigorous it's just it's
simply not rigorous so Alex Jones taking
Ivermectin on his show
um doesn't actually tell us anything
second part is it actually sorts sort of
looks like Alex Jones only pretends to
take the pills and actually drops it
under his desk and doesn't even take the
pill so it may be a scam on that level
as well so let's start looking at the
video and see what we can make of it I
would get the kids out of the room for
this one this is that's a disclaimer
let's let's go care people
a red shot please you know what this is
this is Ivermectin for humans you want
to Nobel Prize isn't antiviral and this
is inhalable or these are the tablet
steroids so let me show you okay so
let's let's stop right there
first of all the steroid why would you
take a steroid unless you need it
steroids are not prophylactic for
viruses steroids reduce inflammation
which is why sometimes they're given we
were we were looking at dexamethasone
when people have real lung compromise
you give dexamethasone to reduce the
inflammation and maybe allow the lungs
to heal but steroids suppress the immune
system and they can actually extend how
long it takes to clear the virus so why
you would randomly take a steroid unless
you're sick and it's been prescribed
steroids have so many side effects from
a mental health standpoint they can
cause Mania panic attacks insomnia it's
crazy right the whole prednisone is one
of the things Rogan took and that's why
that's why it's here but I think Alex
Jones mostly focuses in on the
Ivermectin so let's continue
I was gonna do this anyways earlier
see this watch closely see this voucher
you see this Bill Gates I'm gonna kill
those prions you bastard murderers and
hit him with a bio weapon you monster
you want to suppress me you want to kill
me you son of a [ __ ] you goddamn demon
you think I'm easy to kill
I think I'm gonna roll over to your crap
so listen uh I've looked at this a few
times it does look to me like when Alex
Jones is making a big to do of grabbing
his water or beer or whatever he's using
to slug this
um it looks like he sort of just drops
the pill under his desk I don't know
we'll look at it one more time and
continue I think the point is whether he
really took it or not it doesn't
actually change anything about
Ivermectin I think he might have dropped
the pill below his desk you goddamn
demon you think I'm easy to kill
I think I'm gonna roll over to your crap
no no and Joe Rogan kicked your
murdering ass too you'd love to bury him
too you little monster maggot
he's in this National Geographic piece
about oh I don't usually deal with my
enemies right away I get them later yeah
you creep up on with a poison injection
dressed up in a lab coat you little
Joseph mingla Nuremberg code violating
monsters so these are these are
analogies to Nazi experimenters in terms
of Public Health officials right now you
damn monster
yeah I don't know that he's really
taking the pills see our little cancer
proteins like that Nobel prize winning
for humans no available prize money for
humans no available prize money for
humans no avail prize money for humans
so here he's actually having what
appears to be a psychotic break oh
they're all prize money for humans what
2005. Nobel prize winning for humans oh
Joe Rogan Joe Rogan he is he's working
to drink the horse pay she's stupid I
bet he got it from Alex Jones they're
both so dumb they're both gonna be dead
yeah that's why Joe's worth like 300
million dollars yeah he's real stupid
that's why he lives in a 60 million
house on the river you left this taking
all the shots and dying or the dumbasses
he's the one that headlines with Dave
Chappelle not you you're stupid
and I sure wish you'd wake up
but you sit there calling me stupid an
independent media person that built the
biggest Independent Media operation in
the world that changed the whole
Paradigm with my badass listeners and
you sit around and laugh at us medical
doctors gave that to me it is incredible
it helped my family it helped me it
helped everybody and it's approved for
humans for all sorts of viral stuff but
that murderer fouchy doesn't want you to
know because he wants the planet for
himself and he wants you dead well guess
what though she we ain't rolling over
and dying so easily you little murderer
okay so that's pretty pretty serious
stuff
um now uh imagine seeing that and saying
whoa you know what it it seems like a
pretty logical thing to take Ivermectin
based on what I saw and obviously no
sensible person could watch that and
Come Away with that belief a complete
and total meltdown from Alex Jones but
unfortunately for the people that hear
him talk about his supplements and
colloidal silver and you know who knows
what and they buy that stuff
it's not that different to hear him talk
about taking Ivermectin and prednisone
and I mean he might have been high on
steroids that Mania could be
steroid-induced Mania for all we know if
he's really taking it for no reason so
the this there's two scams here I
already told you about them but then on
top of that there's the sort of social
tragedy
the public tragedy of people who get
medical advice from Alex Jones and it's
it's just a sad State of Affairs for the
country folks really really sad State of
Affairs
one of our sponsors today is Helix sleep
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about Helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you I took the Sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what I needed I often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and I've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all Helix mattresses come
with a 10-year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
I think you will all of my viewers will
get up to 200 off your order and you'll
get two super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video